now it is time for puppy pigskin picks
sponsored by subaru of las vegas
and we have kelsey from the animal
foundation with us this week hi kelsey
good morning it's good to see you nice
to see you tell us about this handsome
boy
this is bird he is a teeny tiny delight
we think he's around two years old he
came in as a stray
he weighs about 13 pounds lots of energy
loves car rides going for walks would be
a great companion for someone
he is so super cute um if someone has
pets at home already do you
know if he does well with other pets we
don't know but we can definitely counsel
people
on the best way to introduce your pet to
a pet just like bert or any other
of the pets at the animal foundation
okay we're going to let you get your
treat in a second kelsey tell us about
the promotion it's still going so today
is the last day for our special holiday
promotion that we're so excited about
uh adoption fees are waived for large
dogs
and adult cats so if you're looking to
adopt now is the time to do so
perfect all right bert it is time let's
let's pick a team it's the broncos and
the raiders this week
already pick the raiders thank you
kelsey thank you
tom bert in fairness he did eat all the
treats but he did go to the raiders
first
if you would like to adopt burke just
give the animal foundation a call the
number
955 5901 there on the screen for you
you do have to make an appointment right
now if you would like to see bert or any
other pet there
shelter will be open today until four
o'clock it is closed tomorrow though
because
of the holiday bert is so cute and
it seems you know they said that he came
in as a stray john but it seems like he
was trained and maybe had a home before
because he knew how to sit
for those treats not every dog could do
that